To celebrate Cinderella, let’s take a look
at 25 things you probably didn’t know about
Disney’s live-action remake of their classic
animated movie.
To prepare to play Cinderella, Lily James
practised yoga every day to help get the right
posture and elegance for her character.
She also took horseback riding lessons for
six weeks.
And to understand how Cinderella maintained
her strength and goodness despite the cruelty
she faced, James researched spirituality,
reading about leaders and pacifists such as
Gandhi.
To help develop the natural rapport real-life
sisters have, director Kenneth Branagh encouraged
actresses Holliday Grainger and Sophie McShera,
who play Cinderella’s wicked stepsisters,
to improvise on set.
To make Cinderella’s world feel both believable
and fitting for a fairy tale, production designer
Dante Ferretti mixed historical reality with
fantasy, taking inspiration from Northern
European architecture of the 16th, 17th, and
18th centuries.
Director Kenneth Branagh wanted Cinderella’s
world to have a 19th-century look.
Which meant the movie’s design team could
include earlier styles of architecture into
their designs.
The set for the palace ballroom took around
9 months to build at Pinewood Studios on the
007 soundstage.
The ballroom’s design was inspired by French
architecture including the Louvre and the
Hotel de Soubise, both of which have grand
staircases.
The ballroom measured 50 yards long, 35 yards
wide and 30 feet high, and had marble floors
and walls, a huge staircase, golden statues,
thousands of flowers, and curtains made from
more than 2,000 yards of material.
In the ballroom, there were 17 huge chandeliers
that were custom-made in Venice, Italy.
The chandeliers had almost 5,000 oil candles,
each of which was lit by hand.
The movie’s design team built the exterior
of Cinderella’s family’s home on location
at Black Park, a country park in Buckinghamshire,
England.
The interiors of Cinders’ home, including
the bedrooms, her father’s study, and the
attic, were built on soundstages at Pinewood
Studios.
Although the story takes place around the
1830s, costume designer Sandy Powell used
artistic license to do what was best for each
character.
So, the costumes aren’t strictly 19th century,
but rather a 1940s version of that era.
Powell approached the film like a storybook
for children.
In other words, she made her designs bright
and colourful with fairly-easy references
as to who was good and who was evil.
Costume designer Sandy Powell didn’t want
Cinderella’s usual outfit to be rags or
a patchwork dress.
Instead, Cinders wears a dress that gradually
deteriorates and fades, but looks like something
she would have worn in happier days when her
father was still alive.
The dress is made of aqua cotton voile and
is influenced by a 1920s floral print with
big pale pink flowers almost hidden in the
material.
Cinderella’s ball gown took months to make
with numerous prototypes, fittings and trials,
which included moving and dancing, along the
way.
To give the dress a light, almost weightless,
look, costume designer Sandy Powell used many
layers of very fine fabric in different shades
of blue, which gave the gown its watery lilac
blue colour.
Nine different versions of Cinderella’s
ball gown were made, featuring more than 270
yards of fabric, lots of petticoats, more
than 10,000 Swarovski crystals, and over 3
miles of hems.
It took 16 people 550 hours to make Cinderella’s
silk organza wedding dress.
Unlike Cinders’ ball gown, only one wedding
dress was made.
For Cate Blanchett’s wicked stepmother costumes,
designer Sandy Powell took inspiration from
1940s photos of movie stars such as Marlene
Dietrich and Joan Crawford.
Powell used a strong jewel-tone colour palette
and a lot of black for the stepmother’s
clothes to give her a sharp edge, in spite
of her beauty.
And she gave the stepmother and her daughters
so many incredible outfits to emphasis the
fact that they were spending all the money
left by Cinderella’s father on their own
clothes.
The stepsisters’ outfits were deliberately
designed with the cheapest fabrics to look
over the top and tasteless.
As well as making the sisters look silly,
this also helped keep the focus on the stepmother.
Of all the characters in the live-action Cinderella,
costume designer Sandy Powell says the Prince
is the one who looks most like his character
in Disney’s animated Cinderella movie.
In this new film, the Prince’s costumes
often feature shades of blue to accentuate
actor Richard Madden’s blue eyes.
And even though it would have been more historically
accurate for the Prince’s uniform to have
tight white breeches with baggy knees, Powell
thought fitted trousers looked more flattering.
Helena Bonham Carter’s Fairy Godmother gown
was almost 4 feet wide, made up of over 130
yards of fabric, featured 10,000 Swarovski
crystals, and had 400 LED lights sewn into
the material so it would light up when she
cast a spell.
There were more than 200 extras in Cinderella’s
ballroom scenes.
These included 25 guards, 20 servants, 54
professional dancers and 30 orchestra members.
The costumes worn by guests at the royal Ball
were inspired by ballroom dance scenes in
classic films such as Italian director Luchino
Visconti’s The Leopard and American director
Alexander Hall’s Once Upon A Time.
Over 3 months of planning and preparation,
including casting, wardrobe fittings and rehearsals,
were needed for the whole ballroom sequence.
And more than 35 assistant directors helped
oversee it.
The shape of Cinderella’s glass slipper
is based on a shoe from the 1890s which costume
designer Sandy Powell found in a shoe museum
in Northampton, England.
Powell looked at different ways of making
a glass shoe, but because the shoe needed
to sparkle, she realised it had to be made
of crystal.
So, over many months, she worked with the
Austrian crystal company Swarovski and they
developed a special piece of machinery to
make the shoe.
Eight copies of the slipper were made, however
none of them were actually worn in the film.
Instead, they were used as props, for example
in the scenes where maidens try on the slipper,
and where the slipper is smashed.
During the ballroom scenes, the filmmakers
used five cameras to make sure they caught
every moment in the dance sequences from as
many positions as possible.
And they also used two cranes to get a sweeping
effect and show the scale of the set and the
dance routines.
To make Cinderella appear as natural as possible,
the movie’s make-up designer kept Lily James’
make-up minimal, and used blusher to highlight
her emotions.
So, in scenes where Cinders is sad, they reduced
the blusher, making her look a little pale.
While in scenes where she was excited or falling
in love, they used more blusher.
To give Cinders more sparkle in the ballroom
scene, the make-up team applied a light-reflecting
lotion mixed with white glitter to Lily James’s
skin, and glitter to her eyelids.
And crystals were placed in her hair.
It took 5 hours to get each extra ready for
the ballroom scenes, as each one needed to
be dressed, made up, photographed, and charted.
The design of Cinderella’s iconic carriage
was inspired by jewellery and jewellery cases.
And because the pumpkin’s transformation
takes place in the greenhouse in Cinderella’s
garden, the design team incorporated elements
from the greenhouse into the carriage’s
design.
For example, the seat Cinderella sits on is
from the greenhouse.
The carriage was 10 feet high, 17 feet long,
and weighed nearly 2 tons.
In fact, it was too heavy to be pulled by
real horses, so the design team had to remove
some of the ironwork used in it and replace
it with light-weight sculptures.
Well there you have it, 25 things you probably
didn't know about Cinderella!
If you’re a fan of Disney movies, check
out my videos on 15 Things You Didn’t Know
About Frozen Fever, and 15 Things You Didn’t
Know About Big Hero 6!
And let me know in the comments below, what’s
your favourite live-action Disney movie?
And who’s your favourite Disney character?
If you enjoyed this video, hit the thumbs-up
button and subscribe for more things you didn't
know and weekly movie reviews and interviews.
Thanks for watching!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!